Oi boa tarde desculpa aí primeiro erro é
sempre assim estou imprimindo Isto é
qualquer coisa que tem muitos muitos
anos uma senhora mesmo neste estado não
disse que idade tem por isso mas já são
alguns anos
E porque é que eu resolvi vir aqui
conversar convosco que vocês estão
educadores
Ah e por que a história começou bem lá
atrás
é bem lá atrás e vocês passaram por que
é que ela está assim o que é uma mendiga
no mínimo
é uma mendiga de reconhecimento não não
não vamos para uma mendiga alguém que
não se ajusta muito vocês
se alguém que não não pense isso não não
teve a ver com droga não não é nunca
fumei
e não não foi álcool
Eu só bebo um copo de vez em quando mas
é mesmo quando tem amigos mas isso é
quando tenho amigos
e também não me meti em grupos
extremistas e por isso daí nisto e foi
excluída não não também não foi por isso
estava dizer porque como são educadores
se calhar faz sentido nasci Numa família
de classe média-alta não outro erro que
a baixa em que o grande objetivo era que
eu fosse feita para ter sucesso da
conseguir ter mais sucesso do que os
meus pais que trabalhavam arduamente mas
não bateu muito certo desde o início
porque a primeira palavra que eu disse
ver ser papá uma disse porque isto na
escola também não correu muito bem cada
vez que os professores mandavam fazer
alguma coisa cada vez que diziam é para
fazer porque
é porque eu mandei consertar essa da
minha escola pelo menos com 50 anos essa
é a minha escola é só a escola em que a
pergunta e sinto que quando o professor
também não perguntava também está em que
vos dizer é uma verdade eu olhava para o
lado e perguntava ao colega pronto
tínhamos uma conversa começávamos a
querer explicar Mas isto foi me
acompanhando porque quem torto mas
estava nunca se direito e
consequentemente a escola a família EA
sociedade o desagrado era real era
permanente e
a determinada altura percebi que eu não
ia mesmo mesmo mesmo agradar eu não ia
conseguir ser feita eu ia manter a minha
atitude de perguntar eu ia dizer vó se
já que não posso ser perfeita é um olhar
para os meus erros o partilhar os meus
erros vou dizer o que é que eu fiz Vou
Assumir fiz isto e vou perguntar como é
que se faz mas não vou perguntar as
mesmas pessoas que normalmente não
gostam dos erros e resolvi começar
primeiro é que de fato e conversos
alguns erros eu fui acumulando Mas
também fui percebendo que ao longo do
tempo EA contendo menos erros daqueles
que eram mais graves comecei a perceber
com muitos eram apenas os erros sociais
maior nas eram aqueles erros que não
eram aceitáveis porque não é aquela não
era a
é aquele não era o princípio não se
pergunta aqui não se vai descalço aqui
como se ali ali e ao fazer todas estas
perguntas ao continuar com este
questionamento Iva benesse de ver
mensagem que partilha imensa gente que
meteu a oportunidade de aprender a
oportunidade de um ver e de aceitar
aceitar aquilo que eu era
independentemente na escola aí E isso
nós professores Apesar de eu ter feito
um pós-doutoramento uma licenciatura em
matemática acreditem que eu até o
segundo ciclo passava
e assim porque por isso mesmo
é porque a escola não era para mim eu
não era para escola
e eu dizia Havia duas dois milagres que
eu queria que acontecesse no mundo um
que não tivesse comer em que bastasse um
comprimido já
bom e que não fosse preciso escola ir
para a escola porque eu consegui
aprender essa cena escola
e felizmente mas este também foi um erro
que não foi muito bem aceito na família
fui para educação era suposto ter ido de
base de Cassia gosto do Pai ensina gosto
da mãe lá na casa o dia um duas elas lá
resolver um esse assunto eu continue a
o e All Star na educação ao percecionar
que rio o outro que partilhavam como é
que transformavam o erro em Sucesso
eu fui necessariamente para as áreas
mais holísticas que me permitiram ver o
mundo mais Ecológico entendimento do
outro não Estava satisfeita entretanto
albume da Inteligência Emocional
Viuvinha da Matemática grande erro eu
vinha da Matemática boa a que fazer
outras licenciaturas porque também não é
grave vamos ter que fazer outra
licenciatura para poder em Portugal
virar da matemática para trabalhar as
áreas da Inteligência Emocional mas isso
abriu outras portas abre uma
possibilidade entendendo a matemática
entendendo a área da Inteligência
Emocional e cruzei com a paixão que
agora partilho convosco a sapatilha
nestes sítios normalmente as paixões mas
pronto é vida cliente a de mendigo pode
partilhar tudo
e a paixão é a criatividade mas a
criatividade a mesma coisa das Artes só
miolinho da Matemática Não eu não tenho
jeitinho nenhum para fazer desenhos até
as crianças pequenas eu faço um cão eles
pensam que uma galinha Esquece Que
jeitinho Mas então EA criatividade não
tem a ver com inspiração só também não
foi isso que eu descobri foi isso que eu
descobri que é possível trabalhar a
partir do erro a pessoa então agora
vamos falar um pouco sobre o que é que é
e o que poderá não ser a criatividade
que atividade pressupõe uma conjugação
entre vários elementos a pessoa essa sua
tem que ter algumas características
a dominar estratégias estratégias que
permitem ir desde aquilo que ela é com
pessoa aquilo que ela possa vir a
construir enquanto produto perguntou
isso que pode ser o discurso pode ser
uma aula pode ser um produto de inovação
de uma empresa de inovação Pode ser que
ela cozinhado em casa não importa tem
que ir desde as características das
pessoas dominar estratégias para
construção de produtos e claro Temos que
estar em ambientes que nos sejam
facilitador ou diminuir ou que nos
diminui a nossas características com
pessoas que são as características com
pessoa colchão
a ter muitas ideias ser capaz de obter
muitas ideias e partilhar essas idéias a
coragem de assumir o erro de dizer as
ideias que eles saem
as ideias de variadas e claro originais
e aqui que originalidade às vezes não
batia lá certo se calhar primeiro para
fazermos a perguntas segunda Por que
perguntas diferentes terceiro porque era
preciso haver a intencionalidade em tudo
aquilo que eu fazia é tudo aquilo que eu
queria ver feito e por isso
eu encontrei e por isso é o meu
apaixonado encontrei o comeu complemento
a resolução criativa de problemas ou
mais internacionalmente Creative problem
solving em trabalho exatamente todas
estas competências desde as
características da pessoa para fazer um
banho de homem bem-estar mim tem
técnicas específicas para fazer não é
vamos um Brainstorm sim mas se houver a
crítica se não houver a partilha
transparente isso não vai acontecer é
quando muito uma Belém confusão não é um
banho Stone por isso trabalhando as
competências enquanto pessoas
desenvolvendo nos enquanto pessoas
tô aprendendo estratégias que promovem
desde o erro desde a identificação do
problema desafio erro situação para
resolver clarificação de qual é
explícita a mente a situação que
queremos ver resolvida o que sai o que
quero porque quero quando quero onde
quero com quem quero isto é
classificação no criativo absolvem
pressupõem que existe muito claro e as
estratégias para fazer isto em seguida
vamos outra vez produzir muitas ideias
para que para ter soluções para este
problema claramente identificado mas
reparem com estes metodologias estamos a
tratar o erro como nosso amigo estamos a
tratar as a ideia como o nosso amigo
porque é aquele que nos vai levar a que
a possível solução e depois muito me
periculosamente temos ter critérios de
tomada de decisão apr
o império políticos cognitivamente bem
construídos para tomarmos uma decisão Em
sim temos a solução que pode vir a ser
inovadora ou não Ou pode ser um falhanço
depois de todo este processo mas como
dizia o Thomas Edson eu não tenho 50 mil
formas eu não tenho 50 mil erros Eu
tenho 50 mil formas que não funcionaram
e é o cliente pela pessoa ouvindo o meu
apaixonado enquanto estrutura
metodológica de trabalho faz em
organizações seja com pessoas seja nas
escolas com os alunos permite Exatamente
isto errar muitas vezes fazer um
processo consciente andou em ir
desenvolvendo as competências de quem
está envolvido astrais competências que
em termos de educação Estão muitas
preconizadas no perfil dos jovens a
saída das coisas da obrigatória e que
são as competências expectáveis para a
empregabilidade e já agora para Av
os pequenos do Emprego A Vida estas
competências criatividade semi-crítico
colaboração comunicação possível que é
preciso saber come carne ideias para que
ela depois a seguir a aqui que eu ia
chegar experimentar ter o medo de
experimentar porque há grande
probabilidade de errar por fora depois
experimentar natal prototipagem
experimentação é que foi buscar a
conclusão que se Está ou não está bem
Este discurso só depois de eu ver outra
vez é que vou dizer não era nada assim
era assim mas só pois se fazer é para a
próxima tá se faz diferente mas nós
somos fruto para mim de na vida creating
problems Will somos fruto de uma coisa
erro segundo ver terceiro aceitar quarto
transformar conscientemente mas este
transformar
a ser casuístico não pode ser hoje
apetece-me ser criativo absorvente
e não não roupa
e resulta Na continuidade resulta como
uma mentalidade com uma forma de
funcionar na sorte conosco primeiro na
relação com o outro e nas organizações
lembra-se
E se nós somos professores nós lidamos
com estudo ou se nós somos agentes
educativos não temos que ser professores
podemos ter apenas agentes educativos
que somos todos é a minha é o meu
pensamento porque para criar uma uma
criança é preciso uma aldeia e daí a
minha grande paixão do trabalho a
trabalhar com o criativo para alguém
sozinho porque junta a estrutura
matemática
e com a criança que disse a primeira vez
por quê
bom e com a possibilidade de fazer
aquilo que é o meu sonho de vida e que
também já que já partilhei convosco ou
da minha paixão também posso virar
partilhar convosco mas daí um bocadinho
Isto é daquele porque antes vou pedir os
para pensar
e esta vestimenta
só foi uma brincadeira convosco acordar
tava com algum medo que estando nos na
época do Sporting o Benfica não não
acordado
quem é
o conhecemos como educadores
e qual é a nossa atitude para com o erro
como é que nós vemos o nosso erro Será
que eu como educador assumo
anteriormente que eu tenho que saber
tudo que eu tenho que ir à aula e o
tenho que preparar a aula da forma e
usar tudo o eu permito esta partilha de
criativo alguém só vim de Vamos explorar
o tema vamos conhecer juntos é claro que
nós temos o domínio da estratégia e
vamos orientado Mas será que permitimos
que eles cometam erros para o caminho
e se não fizermos temos algumas
probabilidades de se não for
explicitamente de alguém de mãos
estendidas na rua fecha alguém que
interiormente está de alma estendida a
pedir por favor reconheçam algum do
valor que eu tenho mesmo que esse valor
não seja apenas saber muitos a
matemática ou saber muito português tal
Como dizia O Rui é importante as outras
competências mas antes disso precisamos
nos perceber esse aqui habita alguém sem
nós habita alguém que habita com esse
som está disponível a fazer este
processo de transformação desde o erro
até o sucesso e o sucesso é construído
por isso essa desafio fica aí tá E agora
como já lancei o desafio
um chá estará preparada para vos dizer
também que a minha a minha paixão estar
convosco
Esse é fato de estar aqui porque entendo
que a vida é um exercício de partilha
sem estes momentos de partilha eu não
teria feito o percurso da menina que o o
segundo anos qualidade que nada queria
saber da escola de hoje sou apaixonada
pela aprendizagem pela escola pela
partilha convosco e também por outro
lado tenho uma outra rumo na minha vida
que é eu quero que cada minuto da minha
vida sirva para impulsionar
positivamente aqueles com quem Cruz e
por isso é meu desejo que em cada um de
vocês hoje se lembrem
é mas amanhã se lembre um continu de
valorizar o vosso reino valorizar o erro
dos vossos daqueles que estão à vossa
responsabilidade e Se tiverem essa
motivação partilha e no comigo porque
está na ser um nasceu está a crescer uma
ideia de À Volta do mundo reconhecer
pessoas que aceitam erraram estão
disponíveis a partilhar numa entrevista
numa conversa algo informal obviamente
que foi mal não batia certo comigo e
esse caminho desde o erro seja pelas
mitologias que eu envie para almoçou vem
seja por outra mitologia por cada um de
nós tem a sua própria mitologia
e por isso convosco quero transformar o
mundo mas de Natal porque o natal é
quando uma mulher quiser bem haja Por
estarem comigo é